we do have breaking news overnight on
another coronavirus vaccine candidate
the most recent testing shows
astrazeneca's vaccine developed at
england's oxford university
works well is safe and is highly
effective for older patients
charlie dagetta has the story it's
peer-reviewed evidence that the oxford
vaccine not only triggers the robust
immune response they'd hoped for
but packs a punch where it's needed most
on older adults
going further the vaccine is even
tolerated better
in older people than younger people the
results published in the lancet medical
journal
reviewed oxford's phase 2 study
involving 560 adults
including 240 people over the age of
70. the group at a significantly higher
risk of severe disease and death
more likely to fill overstretched icu
hospital wards
and earmarked to receive the vaccine
first the good news
from pfizer and moderna was a boost for
oxford's vaccine too
they use a similar approach the study's
chief investigator professor andrew
pollard said the news is encouraging but
not definitive
we're not in a rush we and it's not a
competition with the other
developers what we're trying to do is to
make sure that
we have very high quality data
researchers say they're hoping for more
high quality data in terms of efficacy
and safety in the coming weeks
it's worth remembering that this vaccine
can be stored in a basic refrigerator
rather than a deep freeze gail that's a
good news
very good news thank you charlie dagetta
reporting from oxford